Hello world.
It's Saroj and let's train an AI to create
a set of topics for any news article
that we give it.
We can frame the machine learning
process a lot of different ways.
Learning from data that has
labels, learning from data
that doesn't have labels,
learning how to act on continuous data,
but a more application
focused way of framing.
The learning process is as
either a discriminative or
generative discriminative
models. Tell us what some data is.
They discriminate, differentiates,
classify, call it what you
will. They ask the question,
is this a picture of bitcoin
or bitcoin cash? Seriously,
what is going on there? What language
is this text? Who is singing this song?
What show is this?
What type of object is this?
Generative models are even more exciting.
They generate new data, new images,
new videos, new music, new texts,
which reminds me of a video by
another youtuber named Carey. For now,
just know that there are two neural nets,
a generator and a discriminator that are
each co-evolving evolving to outsmart
the other. Definitely subscribe
to him, put more formally.
Most of the advances in machine learning
have been in discriminative models
where we try to estimate a function
called the posterior probability.
That is the probability of y given x
where x is an input sample and why as an
output.
So we can imagine x to be an image and
why to be the kind of object that is in
the image like a Tesla.
It tells us how much the model believes
that there is a Tesla given an input
image compared to all possibilities.
It knows about generative models.
Instead estimate a function
called the joint probability,
the probability of y and x.
That is the probability that x is
an image and there is a Tesla in it.
At the same time,
the reason we estimate
the joint probability for
generative models is because
using it, we can generate images
of Teslas by sampling car types.
Why and new images acts from
the probability of y index.
There are so many awesome generative
models out there that we could go over.
Auto encoders,
try to reconstruct the input data,
then we can use it's learned dense
representation to generate new types of
similar data. Generative adversarial
networks consist of two neural networks,
one trying to fool the other one by
presenting fake but realistic looking data
as the discriminator improves.
So does the generator until the generated
data is indistinguishable from the
real thing.
But let's start with a relatively basic
one called latent Dirichlet allocation
or Lda Derris. Schley is a type
of distribution like the Gaussian,
it's specified by a vector parameter
containing variables corresponding to each
topic which we write as such.
These are direct laid distributions
for three different topics.
The bottom triangle has a side for each
topic and the closer a point on the
triangle is to aside the higher
the probability of a topic.
The curb is the probability density
function over the mixture of topics,
so the edges of the triangle
all have a zero probability.
Just like the probability Facebook has a
super intelligent AI sensationalist say
yes,
the word latent is there because a
variable we have to infer rather than
directly observe is
called a latent variable.
Since were directly observing
the words and not the topics,
we refer to the topics as the latent
variables as well as a distributions
themselves. We are allocating Leighton
Dera Schley distributions over text data.
LDA is a way to automatically discover
topics from a set of documents and was
created by Andrew [inaudible] who
popularize it in his Coursera course on
machine learning. One of the things
I learned both when I was um,
running the Google team and
now building a team at Baidu
topic modeling isn't efficient way to
analyze large volumes of text data.
There are many use cases for it.
Search engine rankings,
analyzing how research topics
evolve in a conference,
finding out the interests of
different users using their tweets.
Suppose we have a collection of sentences.
We could use Lda to automatically
discover topics that the sentence is
contained. If we want to topics, then
the first topic would be a list of words,
each with percent values that indicate
how relevant they are given a topic in
that category.
The same goes for the second topic.
Then it assigns percent values to each
sentence to define how relevant each
topic is to that sentence.
I think so.
I'm not sure what it was.
I conditioned this result on a
couple of different data sets.
So you applied for it.
Yup. I love it. Well,
we shouldn't submit yet until we can
replicate and we got two weeks left.
I'm going to write the paper.
We can think of.
This whole thing has a three step process.
We tell the algorithm how many
topics we think there are.
The algorithm will assign every
word to a temporary topic.
Then the algorithm checks and updates the
topic assignments looping through each
word in every document.
Now it's look at it programmatically.
We can import our documents using the
pandas library to load our data points
into memory as a data frame object.
We're going to perform some cleaning
steps here straight out of Compton.
I mean the natural language processing
playbook. Since our words matter,
three steps, tokenizing, stopping
and stemming tokenizing segments.
A document into individual tokens
that we define the size of.
Since we're applying
Lda at the word level,
we'll tokenize or document into words.
Once we've converted our documents,
a sack of tokens,
we'll want to remove stop words.
These are the meaningless words that
won't contribute to our topics like for an
or and art history majors.
The very definition of
a stop word is flexible.
We can define that list ourselves
or we can use a predefined list.
It also depends on the topic or modeling.
If we're modeling a collection of music
reviews and been terms like the who will
be hard to model since the
will usually be removed,
even though it's a part of the band name.
Next we'll perform stemming.
This combines similar tokens in our case
words into a single token like a a an a
could be reduced to a.
Now we want to create a document term
matrix because we need to understand the
frequency with which each term
occurs within each document.
The rows are docs in the collection and
the columns are the terms will traverse
through our documents,
assigning unique integer ids to each
unique token while also counting words.
All of this will be
stored in a dictionary.
Now we're ready to generate an LDA
model using this document term matrix.
We'll iterate through every document we
have in our dataset and randomly assign
each word in the current
document to one of our topics.
We'll go through each word in the
documents and for each topic compute to
probabilities.
Then reassigned a new topic.
By using these probabilities,
the probability that we place a word in
the correct topic will increase every
time since we will place more and
more words into the correct topic,
we can examine the results by printing
out the number of topics we chose as well
as a number of words per topic and these
topics seem very news related and the
words seem to be very
relevant to the topic.
So I think we did a pretty
good job to summarize,
generative models learn a
joint probability distribution
between input data and
the labels.
While this discriminative models learn
the conditional probability distribution
between them.
Topic modeling is all about finding
the hidden thematic structure in a
collection of documents and latent
Dirichlet allocation is a generative topic
modeling technique that can
be implemented pretty easily.
Hammad shake is the wizard of the week.
He created a linear regression model
using a Bayesian approach to find the
relationship between movie
sales and movie ratings.
This is very likely the best made
Jupiter notebook on the topic.
On all of get hubs. So take a look
at it for sure. Very well done.
And the runner up is Noah Dell,
who used Basie and optimization to find
the learning rate for a neural network
that correlates bitcoin search
frequency and is price also.
Definitely check that
one out. Great work. No.
This week's challenge is to perform Lda
on a text data set of your choice bonus
points for real world use
cases. Poster. Get help,
link in the comments and winners
will be announced next week.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos.
And for now I've got to find a
better topic. So thanks for watching.